Pig's Feet
Aki-sama isn't here right now. I have a date with Kintsugi today. So
no, that's fine. It's been a
while since I came here, but it's smaller than I thought. But it's
a lot bigger than my house, but I'm
slow and I'm
going to the end of the world.  I felt like it was going on
[Music]
That's not true. That guy in Paris
was acting like he didn't remember what I was called pig's feet. I'm
standing here, bullying you guys.  When I
said it myself, I got
angry and thought, ``I'll never forgive you.''
But, if what he said
was true,
that thought made me nervous.That
voice I heard here was really true.''  Was it Aki Aragaki's?
What do you want to say? At
that time, I thought he was the only child in the house, so I
didn't think about the possibility that it was someone else. According to him, he was in the mansion at
the time with chicken pox and had a
room in his room.  I couldn't get out of the house, but
there was also a child of a servant who was the same age as me,
and he kept watching us.The
only people who knew the nickname "Pig's Foot" were me, the bullies at the time, and the person who gave it the name.  But
Aki Aragaki didn't remember, so
why do you
call me pig's feet?